[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le féminisme ça a longtemps était un
truc de femmes ou d'ailleurs
c'est complètement logique parce qu'on
est quand même les premières concernées
j'aimerais bien voir s'il ya des femmes
dans la salle ce soir fait du bruit s'il
vous plaît ok génial super on a des
femmes c'est top
bon bah qu'est ce qu'on fait des hommes
maintenant est-ce que ils sont concernés
ce qu'ils ont droit d'être féministe je
suis féministe et entrepreneur dans la
mode
entrepreneur depuis l'année dernière et
féministe depuis toujours parce que ça
m'a toujours semblé incompréhensible que
les femmes et moindre connaissance -
liberté juste pour une affaire de sexe
alors être féministe pour moi ça a
toujours été très naturel par contre ce
qui était beaucoup moins naturel c'était
en tant que féministe comme enjeu peut
interagir avec les hommes
est-ce que j'ai besoin de s qui peuvent
être utiles à la question non maintenant
quand j'étais petit en tout cas la
réponse était plutôt non voire même
carrément et bien sûr que non
démonstration les garçons droitière plus
de choses pourtant ils ont de moins
bonnes notes à l'école et c'est prouvé
les politiques c'est tous des hommes aux
cheveux gris pourtant si j'en crois le
cours d'histoire les hommes aux cheveux
gris ont clairement fait n'importe quoi
sur deux millénaires et plus
particulièrement au cours du dernier
siècle quand un modèle ne fonctionne pas
on le remplace cqfd mais qu'est ce qu'on
attend pour remplacer les hommes par les
femmes
voilà là j'étais dans ma période
féminisme anti homme qui s'est nourrie à
la fois d'une volonté de revanche
historique et aussi d'un profond
sentiment d'injustice qui a commencé dès
la cour de récré pourquoi les garçons
ils ont droit de faire la bagarre et
pourquoi moi j'ai pas le droit de leur
mettre une gifle quand aujourd'hui le
jeu des bisous forcé ça m'amuse pas du
tout pourquoi les adultes ils trouvent
ça normal ces différences et pourquoi on
me dit tout le temps
maryline calme-toi c'est normal c'est un
garçon ça fait ça un garçon ah oui bah
c'est nul ce genre d'argument fataliste
c'est normal ça fait ça un garçon gelé
beaucoup entendu trop entendu et à côté
de ça mais deux parents et epci alors
c'était un peu leur boulot de demander
pourquoi donc moi aussi j'ai appris à
poser des questions mais ça me suffisait
pas je voulais remettre les choses en
question est en fait j'avais envie de
changer le monde
alors quand j'avais 17 ans j'ai quitté
d'internât j'ai quitté la bretagne j'ai
intégré sciences po j'ai beaucoup
travaillé j'ai beaucoup fait la fête
aussi et je me suis découverte vie
sexuelle
ça n'a pas été simple tout de suite sur
tous les plans au loin de là mais au
moins sur le plan du féminisme c'était
carrément plus simple à cette époque là
les mecs c'était des potes ou des
sex-toys je crois qu'il y en a qui n'ont
pas trouvé ça très très cool et je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est pas cool c'est
pas cool de prendre quelqu'un pour un
objet mais c'est aussi ce que j'ai vécu
comme plein d'autres fille de 20 ans
dans la rue
en soirée en vacances au quotidien alors
l'accepter enjoué faire la même chose
finalement c'était plus simple plus fort
est presque à une manière de
rééquilibrer les choses
c'était ma période féminisme sans les
hommes ou bien sûr je n'ai pas choisi de
tomber amoureuse d'une femme ni la
première fois ni la suivante
par contre j'ai choisi de m'approprier
la culture lgbt et j'ai découvert un
monde où de fait les gens sont plus
amené à se poser des questions sur ce
que ça veut dire le genre le sexe la
sexualité qu'est ce que ça veut dire
qu'être un homme qu'être une femme c'est
quelque chose qui m'a énormément nourine
mais l'intéressé je me suis intéressé
d'abord tout seul sur internet
en lisant et puis à new york avec ma
copine de l'époque qui était américaine
d'origine asiatique
donc là j'ai découvert le concept d'un
terreau sectional it et à paris aussi on
était en pleine période mariage pour
tous alors j'ai intégré une asso c'était
un combat hyper important pour moi et
j'ai évolué comme ça quelques années
et puis comme on choisit toujours pas de
qui on tombe amoureux
j'ai fini par m'attacher à un homme
s'était pas du tout prévu et ça c'est
super mal passé d'ailleurs gelé trop mal
vécu mais là on va arrêter parce que ça
commence à faire un peu long côté quête
identitaire et surtout j'avais plus
urgent à gérer à cette époque là dans le
registre des crises existentielles
je suis diplômé je fais quoi alors
d'abord j'ai fait de la pub et en
parallèle j'ai pris des cours du soir en
stylisme en couture et je me suis rendu
compte à quel point la mode avait besoin
qu'on change les modèles qu'on présente
des modèles de féminin au pluriel des
femmes qui ont des choses à dire des
histoires à raconter qu'on en finisse
avec les mannequins qui sont là pour
faire joli et pointent en taille 34 et
demi tout mouillé tant qu'à faire
retoucher si besoin
fini tout ça c'est pour ça que j'ai créé
ma marque ypsilon que je me suis lancé
dans le prêt-à-porter féminin et
paradoxalement c'est aussi à ce moment
là où je suis rentré dans ma phase
féminisme avec les hommes
déjà on en a plein je n'ai pas envie de
mettre dans la case tout c'est même à
mon frère il ya des copains il ya des
collègues des mentors des hommes qui ont
envie d'aider qui m'ont aidé mais qui ne
peuvent pas avoir les clés si on leur
donne pas et qui ne peuvent pas se dire
féministe six de base ils ont
l'impression d'en être exclu alors ok
chacun son combat
mais il faut savoir vulgariser et
rassembler si on veut que ça marche
j'ai aussi retenu les leçons de ma
période féminisme sans les hommes en
ayant exploré mon identité fluctuante en
faisant la paix avec le masculin autour
de moi en moi aussi on pour être tout à
fait honnête j'y travaille encore un peu
mais au moins j'ai compris que
fondamentalement on avait le même
problème
le problème c'est pas la domination
masculine c'est la domination d'un
modèle j'en rêvais
r qui enferme tout le monde les hommes
et les femmes alors mettre les hommes de
cotter en dix ans dans les hommes dames
ils ont des privilèges et s'en rend même
pas compte il se comporte trop mal et
sont pas fichus de comprendre ceci cela
ouais ça fait du bien de râler mais ça
nourrit surtout l'idée que le féminisme
c'est notre problème est pas le leur
alors quand un mec me demande
aujourd'hui si je pense que le féminisme
est toujours utile croyez-moi ça arrive
encore très souvent dans ma vie pro et
perso j'ai envie de lui dire mais oui
oui c'est utile le féminisme c'est utile
sur le plan des écarts de salaires des
standards de beauté du harcèlement de
rue il ya encore tellement de choses à
changer
le féminisme c'est utile pour moi mais
c'est aussi utile pour toi parce que si
les femmes sont toujours ramené à ce
stéréotype de douceur toi tu seras
toujours cantonné à ce devoir de
virilité
si les femmes sont automatiquement les
victimes tu sera automatiquement
l'oppresseur le coupable
et si on continue à définir tout le
temps les femmes en opposition aux
hommes
là on s'en sort pas et sortir de
l'opposition met tout le monde d'accord
en général ça passe par une définition
commune et là je crois qu'on a un sacré
souci parce qu'on est en 2016
visiblement le le mot féminisme fait
encore peur un très grand nombre
d'hommes et de femmes
pourtant je suis persuadé que c'est
surtout un énorme malentendu
vous connaissez emma watson n'est ce pas
ok cool
bon pour ceux qui la connaîtraient pas
c'est l'actrice qui joue hermione dans
harry potter
elle a intégré l'onu femmes elle a lancé
un mouvement assez pâle qui font chier
et elle a fait un discours
extraordinaire sur l'égalité hommes
femmes
on aurait pu penser que définir le
féminisme par l'égalité ça aurait mis
tout le monde d'accord c'est quand même
une valeur plutôt sympa et consensuelle
mais sauf qu'en fait non si comme moi
vous êtes féministe vous avez forcément
déjà eu ce type de réaction ah oui le
féminisme c'est les gens qui sont pour
l'égalité hommes femmes c'est ça ouais
moi je suis pas sûr d'être féministe us
et j'ai pas envie qu'on soit tous
pareils
c'est triste et puis après quoi on a
tous des beats on se met à chronométrer
le temps passé en cuisine les hommes ont
peur de nous ouvrir les portes
non franchement nos différences et la
poésie c'est génétique tout ça faut pas
oublier quand même que biologiquement
c'est naturel on est différent ok la
poésie la biologie très bien bon je
trouve tout ça un petit peu facile
d'invoquer leurs arguments d'autorité
nature et biologie quand ça nous arrange
et le mettre de côté quand ça nous
arrange pas mais au fond moi non plus je
suis pas pour l'égalité hommes femmes a
bien sûr j'ai pas pour l'inégalité est
pour moi le féminisme c'est pas une
question d'égalité
c'est une question de liberté d'ailleurs
jeu devrait proposer cette définition
emma watson
ça vous dit si on le fait tout de suite
là maintenant ensemble on fait comme si
on lui écrivait une lettre je pression'
et emma faut que je te dise vraiment
merci
si tu savais à quel point ça fait
plaisir de voir un nouveau féminisme
incarnée par quelqu'un d'accessible cool
et sexy et oui j'ai bien dit cool et
sexy
parce que mine de rien l'image ça compte
et le féminisme aujourd'hui a aussi un
problème d'image d'ailleurs emma serait
tellement cool d'avoir une version
française de toi tu l'auras compris je
suis une grande fan mais passons aux
choses sérieuses
il faut vraiment qu'on parle de cette
définition du féminisme par l'égalité
l'égalité ça suppose systématiquement
une comparaison est une mesure on est
égal à quelqu'un par rapport à un
standard donc sa part d'une très bonne
intention mais ça met systématiquement
les femmes d'un côté les hommes de
l'autre
moi je suis tout le temps ramené dans ma
case de femmes je suis une femme au
point les hommes évidemment sont placés
au dessus et ils ont l'impression de
devoir lâcher du lest nous accorder des
places dans les conseils
d'administration faire attention quand
ils font des blagues faudrait pas être
trop macho faire des efforts sur les
enfants les tâches ménagères et nous il
faut qu'on aille chercher qu'on avait
demandé qu'on nous accorde les mêmes
choses les mêmes traitements le même
statut les mêmes standards
moi franchement les politiques rh de
mixité qui font jolie dans les rapports
rse l'égalité artificielle les quotas
tout ça ça ne me parle pas du tout alors
au fond je m'en fiche d'avoir autant
qu'un homme ce qui m'intéresse c'est
d'être libre
dans l'absolu je veux pas être une femme
égale je peux être une femme libre je
veux sortir des stéréotypes de genre qui
enferme tout le monde les femmes et les
hommes bien sûr dans certains pays où
l'égalité l'accès à l'école ou droit de
vote n'est même pas assurée bien sûr
l'égalité en droit c'est la base
mais quand j'en parle ici en france avec
des copains je vois surtout un énorme
amalgame entre égalité et égalitarisme
d'ailleurs et moi tu constateras emma
disparu obama emma constatera que c'est
un problème français qui dépasse le
féminisme toujours est il que le socle
juridique de l'égalité aujourd'hui il
est là ce dont on a besoin c'est de
changer les mentalités pour qu'on soit
tous plus libre les femmes et les hommes
points non en fait j'ai oublié quand
même un petit psa emma et ben en général
j'aime bien débattre autour d'un verre
de vin et si ton copain féministe justin
trudeau est dispo il est aussi
cordialement invités voilà maintenant
c'est à vous de choisir
à vous de choisir la définition qui vous
convient liberté égalité tout casser peu
importe une définition c'est pas un
combat en soit c'est une manière de
rassembler et de se mettre d'accord
comme vous avez vu j'ai mis un petit peu
de temps et plusieurs périodes de
féminisme pour comprendre que
fondamentalement le féminisme devait
être un combat un mouvement unisexe et
c'est pour ça que je vous propose
aujourd'hui une nouvelle définition du
féminisme qui passe avant tout par la
liberté parce qu on a pas d'un côté ceux
qui sont déjà le standard de l'égalité
et celles qui doivent le rattraper on a
tous à gagner à être plus libre je peux
quand même pas vous quitter comme ça
sans vous faire une dernière confession
et son adresse et plus particulièrement
à vous messieurs je voudrais qu'on soit
bien clair les hommes
je vous comprend toujours pas vraiment
vraiment pas mais je vous aime quand
même et je défendrai votre liberté
autant que la mienne merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]